[Music]
today when people complain about the
state of american politics
they often mention the dominance of the
democratic and republican parties
or the sharp split between red and blue
states
but while it may seem like both of these
things have been around forever
the situation looked quite different in
with the republican party not yet
existing and support for the dominant
democrats and whigs
cutting across geographic divides the
collapse of this
second party system was at the center of
increasing regional tensions
that would lead to the birth of the
republican party the rise of abraham
lincoln as its leader
and a civil war that would claim over
half a million lives
and if this collapse could be blamed on
a single event it would be the
kansas-nebraska act
of 1854. the story starts with the
missouri compromise of 1820
to balance the number of slave states
and free states in the union
it allowed slavery in the newly admitted
state of missouri
while making it off limits in the
remaining federally administered
louisiana territory
but compromises tend to last only as
long as they're convenient
and by the early 1850s a tenacious
democratic senator from illinois
named stephen a douglas found its terms
very
inconvenient as an advocate of western
expansion
he promoted constructing a
transcontinental railroad across the
northern plains
with an eastern terminus in chicago
where he happened to own real estate
for his proposal to succeed douglas felt
that the territories
through which the railroad passed would
have to be formally organized
which required the support of southern
politicians
he was also a believer in popular
sovereignty arguing that the status of
slavery in a territory
should be decided by its residents
rather than congress
so douglas introduced a bill designed to
kill two birds with one stone
it would divide the large chunk of
incorporated land
into two new organized territories
nebraska
and kansas each of which would be open
to slavery if the population voted to
allow it
while douglas and his southern
supporters tried to frame the bill as
protecting the political rights of
settlers
horrified northerners recognized it as
repealing the 34 year old missouri
compromise
and feared that its supporters ultimate
goal was to extend slavery to the entire
nation
congress was able to pass the kansas
nebraska act but at the huge cost of
bitterly dividing the nation
with 91 percent of the opposition coming
from northerners
in the house of representatives
politicians traded insults and
brandished weapons
until a sergeant-at-arms restored order
president pearce signed the bill into
law amidst a storm of protests
while georgia's alexander stevens future
confederate vice president
hailed the act's passage as glory enough
for one day
the new york tribune reported the
unanimous sentiment of the north is
indignant resistance
douglas even admitted that he could
travel from washington d.c to chicago
by the light of his own burning effigies
the political consequences of the
kansas-nebraska act were stunning
previously both whigs and democrats had
included northern and southern lawmakers
united around various
issues but now slavery became a dividing
factor that could not be ignored
congressmen from both parties spoke out
against the act
including an illinois whig named abraham
lincoln
denouncing the monstrous injustice of
slavery in an 1854 speech
by this time the whigs had all but
ceased to exist
irreparably split between their northern
and southern factions
in the same year the new republican
party was founded by the
anti-slavery elements from both existing
parties
although lincoln still ran for senate as
a whig in 1854
he was an early supporter of the new
party and helped to recruit others to
its cause
meanwhile the democratic party was
shaken when events in the newly formed
kansas territory
revealed the violent consequences of
popular sovereignty
advertisements appeared across the north
imploring people to emigrate to kansas
to stem the advance of slavery the south
answered with border ruffians
pro-slavery missourians who cross state
lines to vote in fraudulent elections
and raid anti-slavery settlements one
northern abolitionist
john brown became notorious following
the potawatomi massacre of 1856
when he and his sons hacked to death
five pro-slavery farmers
with broadswords in the end more than 50
people died
in bleeding kansas while nominally still
a national
party douglas's democrats were
increasingly divided along
sectional lines and many northern
members left to join the republicans
abraham lincoln finally took up the
republican party banner in 1856
and never looked back that year john c
fremont
the first republican presidential
candidate lost to democrat james
buchanan
but garnered 33 percent of the popular
vote all from northern states
two years later lincoln challenged
douglas for his illinois senate seat
and although he lost that contest it
elevated his status among republicans
lincoln would finally be vindicated in
1860 when he was elected president of
the united states
defeating in his own home state a
certain northern democrat
who was finally undone by the disastrous
aftermath of the law
he had masterminded americans today
continue to debate whether the civil war
was inevitable
but there is no doubt that the
kansas-nebraska act made the ghastly
conflict
much more likely and for that reason it
should be remembered as one of the most
consequential pieces of legislation in
american history
[Music]
you